[Música]
escala en París Aída Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este espacio de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
hoy en escala en París les hablamos de
la Alimentación quién decide lo que
comemos En qué medida la industria
agroalimentaria impone nuestro menú qué
estrategias se utiliza para influir en
los poderes públicos y para ello
recibimos en nuestros estudios al
sociólogo Joan cortinas bienvenidos Joan
Gracias
profesor de sociología la universidad de
burdeos también es investigador en la
cátedra de salud desianspo de París que
dirige Daniel benamusí con el que ha
escrito este libro lo vi en el lobbies
en el menú lobby o menú en la editorial
francesa es un dashir y que lleva como
subtítulo las empresas agroalimentarias
contra la salud pública toda una
declaración de intenciones Joan comemos
lo que queremos es el sector
agroalimentario al que pone el menú
Bueno un poco de los dos no es decir
cuando uno va a comprar y todos vamos a
comprar o comemos no la tenemos la
información y por otro lado tenemos la
oferta disponible Qué tipo de alimentos
se pueden comprar en los dos casos los
lobbies intervienen Pero evidentemente y
por suerte para nosotros no son los
únicos ahí los poderes públicos que
existen y que trabajan pero los lobbies
es lo que demuestra este libro tienen un
fuerte peso tanto en fabricar la demanda
como en fabricar la oferta es decir la
información como la oferta de lo que
podemos comprar más o menos sabemos que
el sector agroalimentario influye en las
políticas públicas lo sabe la sociedad
pero en este libro muestran cómo actúan
esos lobbies y la magnitud de este
fenómeno explicando diferentes
estrategias no que usan hay muchos
grupos de depresión en este sector Sí
porque es un sector económico muy
importante es el segundo sector en
Francia después de las farmacéuticas por
lo tanto es un con muchas empresas y
sobre todo con mucho músculo es decir
tiene muchos recursos económicos y con
lo cual la cantidad de recursos que
pueden promover y por tanto de
instituciones que pueden movilizar para
defender sus intereses son muy variadas
hemos calculado a nosotros alrededor de
600 actores individuales y colectivos
que se movilizan para defender los
intereses de la industria alimentaria
solo en Francia Existen varios ejemplos
de cómo la industria se ha organizado
para influir no tal vez uno de los
momentos son los que la opinión pública
francesa se dio cuenta del poder que
tienen fue cuando salió aquí en Francia
el nutriscore que ese es el logo
coloreado no que están los envases de
los alimentos y que indica el aporte
nutritivo de del producto en cuestión
entonces vimos que el sector se puso en
contra no querían para nada que que
digamos se les pusiera una nota no una
una letra
ese momento usted cree importante para
bueno investigadores para opinión
Pública para darse cuenta de ese poder
Paralelo que había y que podía influir
en las leyes finalmente fue
importantísimo pero bueno fue digamos la
parte emergida del iceberg que es decir
eso fue un momento en que se visibiliza
pero lo importante y lo que intentamos
demostrar este libro es que el trabajo
de defensa de los intereses del sector
agroalimentario es de todos los días
gente que trabaja todos los días sin que
se vean justamente y lo que reclamamos
es que tendría que ser mucho más visible
en estos momentos la nutriscore permitió
ver ciertas cosas pero es que lo
interesante sería que podría que
pudiéramos acceder a lo que se hace de
manera sistemática y cotidiana que es
ahí donde se hace el trabajo de fondo
nutrirse solo es un momento Digamos como
un concierto para un cantante no ahí se
ve el resultado el trabajo pero el
trabajo viene de lejos no hay un aspecto
muy interesante en este libro que es
explican como instituciones fabrican
conocimientos para servir los intereses
de ciertos sectores no
esto quiere decir que por ejemplo se
fabrican informes para legitimarse
Aunque productos que no son nutritivos
lo que decía antes
lo que queremos bueno por un lado para
poder comer lo que queremos nos hace
falta tener información las autoridades
públicas necesita información para decir
este producto es más o menos sano Cómo
se obtiene esa información con estudios
científicos y ahí es donde una parte de
la primera estrategia de los actores
económicos actúa de manera muy
importante es decir ellos van a
financiar investigación investigación
pública con científicos reconocidos no
quiere decir que los estudios estén
manipulados Y eso es importante tenerlo
en mente no se trata de una manipulación
ni de un complot se trata de orientar la
investigación por ejemplo de un ejemplo
los productos lácteos pueden ser buenos
para prevenir a las enfermedades neuro
operativas pero pueden tener efectos
menos buenos para lo que es el cáncer de
próstata Bueno yo sí soy el actor
económico de la filial lechera voy a
decir voy a financiar un estudio para
ver si realmente mis productos tienen
efecto positivo para prevenir las
enfermedades neurodegenerativas en el
sentido cuando yo promuevo un tipo de
investigación una línea de investigación
dejó de promover otras con lo cual hay
una línea que va a emerger y voy a poder
decir si los resultados son positivos
que los productos lácteos son buenos
para la salud Esta es una manera de
hacer es decir no se trata tanto de
manipulación como de intentar orientar
en favor de los intereses de la
industria otro de los aspectos que
destacan es que hay una estrategia para
desacreditar a través del mecanismo de
la duda explíquenos en qué consiste
cuando hemos perdido la batalla de la
ciencia es decir cuando hay un consenso
científico en la comunidad científica
que dicen no a ver el alcohol no es
bueno para la salud un vaso de vino no
es bueno para la salud todos los días
cuando he perdido la batalla la ciencia
lo que voy a hacer es atacar a los
científicos antes los financiaban Ahora
cuando no puedo financiar más voy a
desacreditar como hay dos estrategias
muy básicas una consiste en decir
vosotros o la gente debe saber que
cuando se estudian temas de nutrición no
se puede experimentar sobre los humanos
no se puede hacer investigación sobre
los seres humanos cosa que es lógica se
hace sobre ratas o ratones bueno que van
a decir van a decir que el modelo o la
estructura genética de un ratón No es
equivalente a la del ser humano con lo
cual todos los resultados que emergen de
la investigación científica y solo
pueden emerger de experimentaciones
sobre ratones vamos a decir que no se
puede extrapolar al ser humano porque no
es exactamente lo mismo con lo cual ya
pongo en duda los resultados científicos
de duda esto impide por ejemplo que se
comercialicen productos más saludables
así en parte evidentemente que sí los
poderes públicos intentan eh No no no no
están completamente digamos sometidos a
la voluntad de los actores económicos ni
mucho menos por suerte pero
evidentemente esta estrategias de los
actores económicos frenan la voluntad de
los poderes públicos con lo cual al
final hay resultados que efectivamente
frenan el nutriscord del cual tú
hablabas costó muchísimo y una ministra
tuvo que comprometer su cargo para
forzar que pudiera haber un nutriscore
pero estuvieron a punto de ganar que no
hubiera nutrido en los paquetes no y a
finales voluntarios no es obligatorio
con lo cual sí que son capaces de llegar
a acondicionar lo que comemos justamente
se aprueban las leyes en la asamblea
nacional y hay medidas que se han
quedado fuera porque la industria
agroalimentaria incluso da las enmiendas
escritas a los diputados para que
bloqueen ciertas iniciativas esto
también ocurre Aparentemente en el
parlamento europeo es muy común esta
práctica de entregar usted presente esta
enmienda cuando se discuta la ley No sí
es muy común y es interesante entender
Por qué Porque no se trata de diputados
mal honestos ni que tengan ni mucho
menos es que los diputados como ustedes
saben emergen del territorio en el
territorio son diputados que son tienen
perfiles académicos XD y no son
especialistas de todos los temas cuando
uno decide la asamblea nacional tiene
que decidir sobre la tele la radio y los
yogures Entonces ellos no pueden saber
de todo evidentemente es mucho más fácil
Cuando uno no es experto convencerle de
ciertas cosas por lo tanto a veces como
no tienen tiempo van justos de
conocimientos sí que pueden recibir
enmiendas que a veces no saben muy bien
De dónde vienen y encontrarla legitima
entonces la van a defender en el
parlamento eso pasa muy a menudo y no
solo en el parlamento francés pasan
muchos parlamentos a incluso clubs en la
asamblea no está el club del cerdo no
que intenta promover los productos
del cerdo esto O sea no hay conflicto de
intereses Dónde está la frontera entre
Lo legal y lo ilegal bueno de momento en
la frontera está Clara Es legal es decir
esos clubs son asociaciones financiadas
por la industria y animadas por agencias
de comunicación especialistas en la
comunicación como les decía un trabajo
importante es convencer a los diputados
de la importancia de defender los
productos en este caso franceses no el
jamón el queso etcétera estos clubes sí
que son legales Por lo cual ellos
organizan comidas los diputados son
libres de ir o no ir Y si ellos decían y
Eres totalmente legal pero evidentemente
ese tiene repercusiones en la percepción
que los diputados tienen ciertos
productos que de nuevo van a fabricar
van a influenciar la manera en que ellos
van a decidir en la asamblea nacional
hace unos meses hubo una sentencia
encontrada una aplicación no
que justamente lo que hacía era a través
del teléfono mirar no En las etiquetas
de los envases la calidad de los
productos y ha sido condenada o sea los
lobbys llegan incluso hasta
hacer que la justicia condened este tipo
de iniciativas es preocupante esto sí es
preocupante pero no porque la justicia
esté corrompida que no lo pienso
sino por porque es preocupante porque
eso demuestra la fuerza de esos lobby es
decir como yo decía antes no es tanto
que los poderes públicos los jueces
tengan Mala Fe ni mucho menos sino que
el trabajo tan masivo y de fondo que
ellos llegan a hacer convence llega
convencer a las autoridades públicas de
buena fe de la de las razones de los
actores económicos el estado francés
está perdiendo peso en las políticas de
salud en favor de los lobbies difícil de
responder a esa pregunta En todo caso el
estado francés como todos los estados es
una composición de ministerios con
intereses distintos y en todo caso
históricamente el Ministerio de salud
que es el que defienden de nuestra salud
aquí en Francia hasta el momento
históricamente ha pesado mucho menos que
el Ministerio de agricultura que es el
que defiende el defiende la gran
industria alimentaria en este sentido sí
que podemos decir que mi historia de
salud pesa mucho menos a uno hoy en día
que en mi historia agricultura y bueno
ante este panorama que hay que hacer No
usted te hablaba de más información más
transparencia que hay que hacer para
restar un tampoco esa influencia y que
se hagan políticas para el común de los
franceses o de la humanidad no pensando
en su salud Bueno eso es un debate que
tiene que ser democrático tiene que ser
un debate abierto y no no me toca a mí
decidir pero en todo caso lo que
insistiría es que me parece que las
prácticas que son muy poco visibles y
muy poco transparentes sesgan el debate
público que tiene que ser una decisión
democrática basada en conocimiento por
lo tanto primero hay que abrir el
conocimiento tenemos que saber Quienes
son los lobbies cuántos recursos
utilizan Quiénes son las personas que
trabajan para ellos y eso hoy en día es
muy difícil de saber por lo tanto para
empezar tendríamos que abrir las puertas
de los lobbies agroalimentario que la
gente sepa cómo esta gente trabaja para
poder tener un debate honesto abierto y
democrático y que decidamos cómo tenemos
que regular nuestra nutrición Bueno
después de haber hecho esta
investigación lo vis en el menú cuando
usted va al supermercado está mirando la
letra pequeña o como hace sus compras
Pues la verdad que te voy a decir que
antes de empezar esta en 2018 no lo
miraba y evidentemente cuando uno va
hablando con nutricionistas y
especialistas va con mucho más cuidado y
sí miro el nutriscore no lo utilizo
sistemáticamente la aplicación Yuca
también la utilizo y En definitiva el
conocimiento que todos tenemos un poco
de sentido común de lo que hay que comer
y lo que hay que evitar no comer muy
Amén pues muchísimas gracias Joan
cortinas autor o autor de este libro
lois en el menú por habernos explicado
estos entresijos de la industria
agroalimentaria gracias a vosotros y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que también
nos pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y france24.com hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]